here with reaction South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham is with US
senator welcome to program good to have
you thank you yeah I wish I was there
thank you you know Joe Biden even today
they're pushing Israel to hit the pause
button yeah and I'm trying to understand
why they would do that because when you
hit the pause button they get to rearm
when you hit the pause button they get
to resupply whatever they need when you
hit the pause button they get to rest
strategize uh shouldn't they be out
there winning the war that that they
didn't start that they didn't want that
they now have to finish I miss Trump how
many of you believe if Trump were
president none of this would be
happening well let me aski how do you do
you believe this wouldn't happen yeah
okay okay here's what I believe if we
were president tomorrow it would stop
tomorrow but let's talk about Hillary
Clinton old bitter and defeated is no
way to go through life so I support
president Trump it's the offensive to me
to suggest I'm supporting Adolf Hitler
because she disagrees with the way he
does business here's what president
Trump did he recognized Jerusalem as the
capital of Israel he recognized Golan
Heights as part of Israel he got six
Arab Nations to recognize Israel as a
legitimate one and only Jewish State
that's not ad off Hitler that's the
strongest supporter of Israel in modern
American history Donald Trump did more
for Israel than any single president on
Biden's watch more Jews have been killed
since the Holocaust Hamas saw weakness
they acted and I'll tell you this if one
American is killed by Shiite militia
supported by Iran if one of our soldiers
is killed in Iraq and Syria we should
blow the Iranian oil refineries to
smithin we should destroy their ability
to fund terrorism let Iran know tonight
you kill an American we're coming after
you let me ask you Senator under Barack
Obama and Joe
Biden they made this Iranian deal which
I thought was nuts giving them billions
of dollars under Joe Biden Iran has now
been able to sell oil it's estimated
they made between 80 and hundred billion
doar then the6 billion dollar uh in
payment as a ransom for five hostages
what what is it about Joe Biden and
Barack Obama and Democrats that think
that they can negotiate with the the
number one state sponsor of Terror I'm
I'm not understanding it well uh when
Obama's president uh Putin invades
Ukraine right when Trump's president
everybody runs and hides in the corner
uh when Biden's President Putin invades
Ukraine again when Biden's president
Hamas kills more Jews than any time
since the Holocaust
uh Afghanistan started this when he left
Afghanistan uh a shameful act that set
in motion everything we're talking about
this is the same Administration that is
having more illegal immigrants cross our
border illegally than all presidents
combined they don't know what they're
doing on the border they don't know what
they're doing when it comes to bad guys
if you had Donald Trump as President we
would secure the Border tomorrow people
would listen to him in Mexico and other
places because they're afraid of him if
he were president of the United States
this stuff with Iran would end the only
thing that works with bad guys is to be
strong our border is broken our policies
don't work it's a matter of time to a
bunch of Americans get killed I will not
vote for one dime for any country
including Israel until we first secure
our own border hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else